and let's let's just do this check it
out yeah what you are seeing is the
website parlay
this is i guess it's the conservative
refuge
they banned i i i guess people have been
using it a whole lot i signed up a year
ago i never really used it
but they banned katie hopkins i think
that's who it was right yeah and then
all of a sudden everybody
flooded in and guess what you've got a
bunch of persona non-grata types
who have been banned from everywhere
else that are active here so parlay is
seemingly the place to be
yeah but for me i couldn't fit 880
characters on twitter
so i wrote this on parlay check it out i
like doing this too i like doing uh
exclusive parlay stuff
yeah i like that well it's it's it's
just it's a blog post you know twitter
is is like two
i couldn't fit it but this was yeah
right this was this was more
conversational so here's what i wrote
you ready for this what happens the end
of this year how does the civil war
start
someone sent me this message and this is
what i crafted from it november 4th 2020
michigan turns red giving trump just
enough electoral college votes to win
re-election
governor whitmer intervenes and decides
that the electoral college votes should
go to the popular vote winner
democrats declare victory republicans
declare victory
both sides accuse each other of cheating
democrats insist the state has the right
to choose and republicans file suit
far leftists go insane in the streets
smashing and destroying things
republicans sit at home crossing their
fingers scotus will side with them
order breaks down completely trump
invokes insurrection act to quell the
violence
democrats insist this is it trump is
trying to take over just like we warned
civil war 2.0 this is just an extremely
pessimistic view of what could happen is
extremely unlikely
someone emailed me making this point and
i thought it was interesting oh man
the optimism in me is like oh i gotta i
gotta shoot this down
the reason why it's not gonna happen the
reason why i thought i could
actually it's very viable well
frighteningly so this is why
i thought about highlighting this point
is that i've heard a lot of things
a lot of talk of what starts a civil war
this made the most sense absolutely how
it does make a lot of sense
both sides declare victory yeah it's
that simple now ladies and gentlemen
there are a lot of comments from people
who are saying things like i wouldn't
have believed it a year ago i wouldn't
have believed it two years ago
it's 2020 anything is possible i bring
you now
to two stories which show me
it's possible first a democratic state
senator was brutally beaten by the far
left
so we'll get more in depth into this but
i want to highlight the fact that the
violence has reached a point where
elected officials are being beaten in
the street
wow yeah listen you can talk about
antifa and the proud boys and like ah
who cares that someone throwing a brick
through window oh it's some dude
stealing from a storefront no this was a
democratic state senator
who uh was out and seeing these these
riots
trying to take a picture from a video
and they started beating the crap out of
him he locked himself in his office i
guess
so that's that's where we're at right
now they tore down a statue of an
abolitionist it is it is it is well
beyond anything making sense
yeah they don't make any sense an
absolute statue and they're like we
gotta bring it down
yep even even if it was their their side
they're just literally
it's like the far left is a fire yeah
it's proving that it has nothing to do
with
any sort of you know message they're
trying to put across they're just trying
to burn the system down the people
themselves are
the fire yep they're just whatever they
can get grab onto and destroy gets
destroyed it's like
it's a zombie horde man they're going
around just beating and biting and
stomping
so we'll come back to this later but i
wanted to highlight this because this
shows the level of violence
yeah where democrats i want what would
happen
it's the end of june what do you think
would have happened if that was a
republican
i don't know and and and the mob came up
and started punching and striking him
he'd be dead
who would be dead how would they know
though no no the republican wouldn't be
dead no oh he'd fight back
no no no no no i think the protesters
would be dead
i think the republican would be when a
cowboy hat and he'd be like bang bang
bang
yeah he'd fight back fight back is one
way of putting it yes that's
nice so i don't look a wisconsin
republican
you know have a sidearm or i don't even
know what the legality is of wisconsin
i don't know i just think you're
substantially more likely to see a
republican
armed for a lot of reasons i'm also
surprised this guy didn't have armed
security democrats love doing that
especially especially in in the midwest
now it's not chicago but in chicago i'm
sure they're gonna
they're gonna wise enough now yep nancy
pelosi is probably like wait a minute
oh dude that's not what we contracted
those people to do
she's got armed guards they all do they
they tell you you can't
that's one thing that that's always
bothered me in chicago yeah that
and it's something my dad used to say
and we're like chicago liberals he'd be
like
it's pretty it's pretty funny they'll
tell you you can't have a gun but then
they can carry around theirs right yeah
i think i think in chicago the aldermen
are legally allowed to carry too really
i could be wrong about that this is a
long time ago i was a kid but anyway
this is just to showcase the violence
right
state senator attacked by protesters as
demonstrations turned
by protesters demonstrated dude it is a
mob
testers those aren't protesters thank
you
and then there's there's like rioters
that are taking over and burning stuff
down
yeah those people aren't the protesters
that are protesting legitimately
right there's a huge difference these
people pumping them up news what are you
doing that's what they do
yeah but that brings me to the next bit
which should be
the worrying part of all this yeah could
it be that some state now michigan was
maybe the wrong choice
i chose michigan because governor
whitmer is
very awful well aren't they trying to
vote
oh yeah isn't there like there's recall
petitions check this out
what you are seeing is the national
popular vote interstate compact
have you heard of this i haven't i
haven't
here's the general idea a bunch of the
most part blue states
believe that the popular vote winner
should be the president
but the current system is that the
states choose their electorates and
electoral votes
go to whoever you know right okay here's
their plan
instead of abolishing the electoral
college we all
agree that if we have 270 votes between
our
pact then we all give our votes to the
popular vote winner
regardless of what the states vote for
it is one of the stupidest ideas i have
ever heard
these people clearly have not thought
things through you know why how come
right now california has 55 electoral
votes okay
when will it ever give those to a
republican never you know why
because it is it is what 65 to 70 blue i
think it's 70
blue hugely yeah meaning right now on
its own it will
always be blue good point they decide to
do this uh national popular vote compact
because they think the republicans can
ever win the popular vote
could you imagine what would happen in
the streets of california if donald
trump won the popular vote and
california went
we have to give it to trump now oh man
2024
yeah they get all the they get all the
electoral votes they have enough states
now
so they have 270 votes it's guaranteed
they're all laughing saying no we will
always have democrats and then trump jr
wins
and then california goes um
i know that 75 percent of you voted for
you know swalwell yeah cheat election
cheat
an election but uh because of this
compact
we've got to give all of those votes to
trump jr now there's nothing
to make california give republicans vote
the only thing this does is
it is create the possibility that blue
states solid blue states will give their
votes to a republican it's the stupidest
idea i've ever heard
yeah but they're thinking that they can
win once they get the popular vote it'll
never go republican again that's wrong
it's insane
because republicans could certainly just
alter parts of their of their you know
uh of their platform that's a good point
but here's the bigger point right now
they have
196 electoral votes guaranteed in the
compact they need 120 and these are
pending meaning
we're really close to them getting this
however
let me read this for you they say the
national popular vote interstate compact
is an agreement among a group of u.s
states
and d.c to award all their electoral
electoral votes
to whichever presidential candidate wins
the overall popular vote in the 50
states and the district of columbia
the compact is designed to ensure that
the candidate who receives the most
votes nationwide is elected president
and it would come into effect only when
it would guarantee
that outcome and there's and that's the
main point
what if november 3rd everybody goes in
votes
yeah november 4th moody's analytics
this is this is pre-pandemic mind you
said that with maximum
historical turnout democrats win by only
a few electoral votes
and that with normal turnout trump will
win
heftily to say the least yeah let's say
because of kovid
it becomes very very close and because
of mainland voting turnout is really
high
the democrats come shy of about 30 votes
so california says
but because we signed this compact if we
give our votes to the national popular
vote winner
it would guarantee the outcome like it
says
yeah that but that feels a lot off a lot
like california's just picking
who the president is instead of the
people well cal but
it's they don't know who's gonna win
they don't know who's gonna win the
popular vote oh they wouldn't uh
they see it and then say if we switch
then democrats win okay
well they but they can't enact it unless
it it guarantees the outcome so they
have to at least
there's a check to see so like they
would know
so let's say when it comes to election
night okay
everyone votes and california sees that
if they give their electoral votes to
the popular vote winner it will
guarantee the
outcome that's exactly what it sounds
like there california is picking the
president not the american public but it
could be
georgia it could be illinois it could be
new york i'm just using them as an
example
well any of those examples i don't like
because again it's putting it on one
state
to make the choice right that's that's
not okay for me
any one of these states could arguably
be like well our state chooses otherwise
the supreme court's apparently going to
rule on what's called a faithless
elector
some someone unlike an electoral vote
who decides to vote a different
direction you're not supposed to do that
apparently
so i i don't think this act what they're
saying here actually strikes the heart
of what the count with the compact
is the compact is supposed to be that if
you can guarantee 270
then you all give your votes to the
popular vote
how much you want to bet after
everything the democrats have done
with every scandal they're not trying to
they're going they're going back to the
china thing
that china that trump trying yep they're
trying to they really think that trump's
working with china
no they're lying i know but it's like
that's
ridiculous he's like the most outspoken
anti-china
everything like we got to bring it back
to us like how is that
oh my gosh think about it man it's so
silly what's the what
doesn't it seem plausible that one of
these states will just be like
because of the net you know the the the
mnp vic
we are going to give our votes to joe
biden and then
all the republicans will say no we won
the electoral college
now to be fair california already gives
its votes to the democrat that's a bad
example
right a better example is a swing state
like you know pennsylvania wisconsin or
michigan
that's why i use michigan in the first
place let's say michigan
goes red but then they say yeah but
biden won the popular vote so we should
give our electoral votes to him it's the
will of the people
good song yeah goes home then donald
trump and the republicans say no
we won fair and square the people have
spoken yeah then they start arguing 11
percent of the population should not
elect a president
and then both sides say they're winners
then what
you know what i think boogaloo too baby
every single police officer in every
major city
will will with a smile and a handshake
break the constitution enforce
unconstitutional edict
towards for who for the governors for so
whatever the government whether the
governor is democrat
they'll go for whatever they're saying i
think public and they'll say
do whatever i think in big cities
the cops will just do whatever they're
told even if it violates the
constitution
i complete i 100 believe that we already
saw it happen when covet happened
all you look when they tried enacting
the gun control stuff in virginia
what did the sheriff say nope not going
to do it never going to do it yeah
and we've seen stuff i think it was like
in oregon too yeah there are a few
places
the the small town cops and sheriffs are
like never going to happen you can't
make me do it yeah
but the big city cops like a few miles
from here with that gym
the cops the smile on their face walk up
and say how's it doing how's it going
ma'am oh that constitution i lit it on
fire a long time ago now you're under
arrest
i did a southern accent for new jersey
oh that was weird it is south jersey
yeah does that count they talk more like
this hey
hey hey you don't get no constitutional
rights here get out of here
is that that's long island is it long
island that's new york
that was more in new york i have no idea
what people are talking about it's the
same
it's all the same thing so so what
happens if it
if it all uh if it comes to this i think
the conservatives and moderates have
proven they're unwilling to fight
at all period they're sitting back some
of them are paying attention
like you know people like you guys
watching for the most part pay attention
that's why i did the rant
you know the other day yep but like i
was mentioning um
i had a conversation today with a very
ardent trump supporter who was just like
ah we're gonna win it's fine
we're gonna win and i'm like you really
think so i was like i don't know aoc
just won her primary
like landslide now we're going to win
and i'm like they're burning down
buildings and tearing down the founding
fathers
i mean no one's doing anything about it
she was going against a republican today
or yesterday or another democrat
for the spot centrist democrat so that's
not really the same thing
it's like just because she won just
means that there's democrats that prefer
her
over the other democrat that's not
saying much
these are the activist democrats too
right the ones who are willing to go to
a primary
yeah exactly the issue is i me
i don't know man if if
if the democratic voter base that is not
activist
is unwilling to vote in a primary why
would they vote against her in general
if they're not paying attention they're
not paying attention but that's not the
point that i was making though they're
going
they're not going up against the
republicans or they weren't yesterday
but they will be so the republicans that
do show up and vote
all these activist democrats are going
up against that group and that's a much
bigger group
so aoc it's not going to be as easy to
win
she's probably awfully comfortable i'm
just i'm just making that point though
that's who she's going up 79 of that
district is swings
democrat so can't can the other group
which is not entirely republican it's
also somewhat independent
who knows will they get up and vote
against her my point is
if she has that level of democrat when
it comes time to vote
i really don't see republicans getting
up and voting
in new york 14 they don't care yeah
they're not gonna do anything
you know the republican in 2018 didn't
even have a website apparently
really yeah don't even bother it's like
listen man i don't understand you think
it's a foregone conclusion
or or whatever but if you aren't even
running why would anyone
vote for you so you wonder why ny 14 is
d
plus 29 well maybe it would be d plus 10
if
if actual republicans voted and actually
talk to the community
yeah but there's no in so many of these
places
no one wants to invest any money or time
or energy explaining very simple things
and the funny thing is
a lot of these people in the city are
very religious especially in this area
which is very latino
a lot of abuelitas christian catholic or
otherwise well i mean the left is
is basically burning down uh trying to
burn down jesus now so it's like maybe
they might come around thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8 pm if you want to
catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you